Guten Tag, mein Name ist Yusuf Sejkin. Ich bin heute der zuständige Arzt für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen. Dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht, mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Hans Bränsler.
Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen nach Samen buchstabieren?
K-A-N-S
Nachnamen?
B-R-E-N-Z-L-E-R, Bränsler.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Bränsler?
Ihr Gebussdatum bitte?
21.08.1943
Könnten Sie es wiederholen bitte? Das ist ein Verbindungsschleppproblem.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter.
Ihr Gewicht bitte, Herr Bränsler?
Ich bin 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin heißt Frau Müller.
Was führt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Bränsler?
Frau Doktor, ich habe viel Angst. Es geht mir nicht gut.
Ich sage Ihnen, seit ungefähr 5 bis 6 Monaten, nein, 8 Monaten stimmt es etwa mit meinem Gedachten nicht.
Am Anfang habe ich nur Kleinkarten vergessen, die ich mit meinem Brille hingewiesen habe.
Oder was ich vor zwei Stunden gemacht habe.
Was ich im Fernsehen geschaut habe.
Aber jetzt ist es so schlimm. Ich weiß oft nicht mehr, was gestern war.
Ich weiß noch.
Ich würde das fragen. Sie können sich erinnern, aber noch nicht.
Ja, Herr Doktor, Sie haben recht. Meine Jugend, meine Arbeit und alte Geschichten, das alles habe ich in meinem Kopf.
Aber das neue nicht.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Ja, ich war oft mein Hausarzt. Aber er hat mir gesagt, das ist normal. Sie sind alte Menschen.
Ich habe viel Angst. Ich denke, das ist nicht normal.
Deswegen keine Sorgen bitte. Wir sind für Sie da und wir tun alles für Sie, Herr Bränsler.
Aber diese Probleme sind immer schlimmer geworden.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder Kopfverletzungen, Herr Bränsler?
Kopfverletzung? Ich habe nicht gehört. Nein.
Sind Sie gestürzt?
Nein, Doktor.
Ist Ihnen oft ohnmächtig, Herr Bränsler? Haben Sie das Bewusstsein verloren?
Hatten Sie oder?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe nicht gehört. Nein.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wie wohnen Sie, Herr Bränsler?
Ich wohne mit meiner Frau.
Zu Hause?
Ja, wissen Sie Doktor, meine Frau, liebe, viele sprechen. Sie sprechen immer jeden Tag.
Aber ich höre manchmal nicht gut. Ja, Doktor.
Haben Sie auch Hörstörungen?
Ja, vielleicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber manchmal habe ich meine Frau nicht ganz verstanden.
Habe Sie Sehstörungen, Herr Bränsler?
Sehstörungen? Ja, ich habe nicht gehört. Aber Doktor, ich habe viel Angst.
Jeden Tag frage ich mich, was passiert mit mir?
Es macht mich nervös und wütend.
Ja, wie gesagt, machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, Herr Bränsler. Es ist zu früh, etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Jetzt führen wir ein Anamnesgespräch durch. Danach werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser dafür, für die Beschwerden?
Ja, wenn ich ein bisschen stressig bin, denke ich, dass es sehr schlecht war.
Aber ich meine, hatten Sie Probleme in Ihrem Leben, in Ihrer Familie oder mit Ihren Freunden oder Freundinnen?
Ja Doktor, deswegen diese Beschwerden möchte ich nicht etwas oder niemand treffen.
Ich möchte immer schlafen. Ich bin erschrocken. Ich habe keine Möglichkeit.
Haben Sie Gedanken, dass Sie nicht mehr leben möchten?
Ja, vielleicht manchmal. Es ist für mich sehr schlecht zu leben, Doktor.
Ist das normal?
Ja, wie gesagt, es ist zu früh, etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Bränsler.
Ich kann nicht mehr gut konzentrieren, Doktor.
Aber Sie sind konzentriert.
Ich möchte nicht mehr im Saal.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpen, Herr Bränsler?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen Taubheizgefühl oder Krippen aufgefallen?
Ja, Sie haben Recht. Manchmal schüpfe ich an meinem rechten Bein Krippen.
Rechten Bein?
Ja.
Haben Sie Muskelschwache?
Muskelschwache? Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Können Sie laufen?
Ja, ich laufe. Aber ich bin alt. Ich bin nicht lange Zeit laufen.
Aber mein Supermarkt, wissen Sie, es gibt in meinem Haus nur ein Supermarkt.
Ich gehe dort für Einkaufen, Doktor.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig?
Schwindelig? Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfuß, Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel, Herr Bränsler?
Nein, ich habe keine übel.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen lecker?
Nicht gut, Doktor. Ich habe viel Angst. Ich möchte nicht essen.
Seit wann haben Sie wenig Lecker?
Seit sechs Monaten.
Haben Sie in den letzten Jahren Ab- oder Suge genommen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe fünf Kilogramm innerhalb sechs Monaten Abgezogen.
Ist Ihnen zuviel zu tun?
Ich habe eine chronische Verstopfung, Doktor. Aber sehr lange.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Vielleicht seit 20 Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich habe eine größere Mitte von DM verwendet.
Plastische Mitte nehmen Sie?
Plastische Mitte. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie die Name ist.
Richtig. Was hast du? Alles noch nicht, oder?
Was hast du? Ich habe einiges Probleme mit meinem Prostat.
Ich muss sehr oft in die Toilette gehen.
Wie oft gehen Sie in die Toilette?
Zweimal.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden.
Ich meine, die Probleme mit dem Wasser.
Sie gehen zwei oder drei Mal nach der Toilette.
Seit zehn Jahren, Doktor.
Können Sie gut schlafen, Herr Bresla?
Ich habe gesagt, ich möchte immer schlafen.
Aber deswegen habe ich meine Wasserprobleme.
Ich muss drei Mal nach der Toilette gehen.
Schlafen, Doktor.
Schlafen, Herr Bresla.
Ich habe eine chronische Krankheit.
Können Sie mich hören?
Ich habe eine mögliche Krankheit.
Haben Sie eine chronische Krankheit, Herr Bresla?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Herr Doktor, es gibt eine verbundenen Probleme.
Können Sie ein Video machen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie eine chronische Krankheit?
Doktor, ich habe viele Krankheiten.
Ich bin alt.
Ich habe Herzprobleme.
Herzinfuzienz.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit 20 Jahren.
20 Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme viele Medikamente.
Spirolakton, Furasemit, Kanda-Sartan.
Ich habe auch Arteriele Bluthochdruck seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Kanda-Sartan und Furasemit, oder?
Ich bin kein Anung.
Ich habe diese Medikamente sehr lange angenommen.
In welcher Dosis? Spirolakton?
Jetzt nicht, Doktor.
Ich habe mich nicht erinnern.
Ich habe alle vergessen.
Haben Sie Ihre Unterlagen mitbringen?
Ihre chronische Vorgeschichte?
Bitte wiederholen.
Haben Sie Ihre Unterlagen mitbringen?
Nein.
Vielleicht kontaktiere ich meine Hausarztin.
Ich kann mit Ihrer Hausarztin kontaktieren.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen, Herr Brenzler?
Mein Nierenwert ist ein bisschen hoch.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, ich habe Nierenerkrankungen.
Was das ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Diagnose festgestellt.
Aber meine Hausarztin hat mir gesagt, ich habe Nierenprobleme, Doktor.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Prostata-Probleme.
Ja, Prostata-Probleme auch.
Sen-Sen Jahren.
Prostata vergrößert, oder?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Was ist das für eine Prostata?
Ich habe keine Medikamente, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, Doktor.
Ich habe eine Galenblase-Operation durchgeführt.
Wann war das?
Vor 40 Jahren.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Allergien? Ja, ich habe immer alle Allergien.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, Jukreis, ja, Jukreis, mit Jukreis.
Beide?
Ja, beide. Und ich habe Nasenverstopfung, trennende Augen, ja Doktor.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Bresla?
Nein.
Haben Sie geraucht?
Nein, ich habe nicht geraucht.
Ich freu mich.
Gelegentlich beim Freundestreffen oder eine Ferne, ja, ein Glas Wein, zum Beispiel ein oder zweimal per Monat.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich aus medizinischen Gründen, fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, Doktor.
Haben Sie Kinder, Herr Bresla?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja, alle sind Erwachsene, ja, gesund, ganzheitlich.
Was wagen Sie vom Beruf, Herr Bresla?
Sie sind, ich glaube schon, im Rentner?
Ja, ich bin Rentner, natürlich. Als früher habe ich als Lehrer gearbeitet.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ihr Vater und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, mein Vater und meine Mutter sind beide wegen eines schlechten Unfalls gestorben, Doktor.
Mein sehr beileid, Herr Bresla, das war ein Autounfall oder?
Ja, wegen Auto. Vielleicht gibt es Verbindungprobleme, ich meine die Kamera aus.
Alles klar. Leider hatten Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater hatte Glutoktok und Er hat Dementz.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hatte Zuckerkrankung und arterielle Hypothenie.
Haben Sie Gechibis?
Ja, ich habe zwei Brüder, aber ich habe keinen Kontakt.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich habe nicht mehr. Es ist sehr alt, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Waren Sie in Lesterzeit im Ausland, Herr Bresla?
Nein, Doktor, ich bin immer in Deutschland.
Ich habe viele wichtige Fragen gestellt, Herr Bresla, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, Doktor, was habe ich? Ich habe viel Angst.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, Herr Bresla, wir sind für Sie da. Wir tun am besten für Sie.
Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Danach werde ich eine Diagnostik voranlassen. Mit dem Ergebnis können wir mehr übersprechen.
Okay, ich warte auf Sie, Doktor.
Bleiben Sie bitte hier.
Okay. Heute habe ich dich sehr schwer gemacht, Yusuf.
Ich würde Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Hans Bresla, einen 82-jährigen Patienten, geboren am 21.08.1943.
Er ist 1,65 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns aufgrund von 5 bis 8 Monaten bestehender, zunehmender Amnesie sowie Konzentrationsstörungen.
Er berichtete, dass die Beschwerden im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert sind.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über Höchststörung, Nervosität und Suizidalgedenken.
Die Frage nach Tachikardie, Parasite, Unfall, Kopfverletzung wurde verleint.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über Parasite.
Er sei schon vielmals deswegen beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Der Hausarzt sagte, dass diese Beschwerden normal sind.
Er gab an Stress, dass die Beschwerden verschlimmert sind.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inapetens.
Seit 6 Monaten hat er 5 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Er leidet seit 20 Jahren an Obstepation.
Dagegen nimmt er pflanzliche Arzneimittel.
Er leidet seit 10 Jahren an Niktug und Polakissug.
Er leidet an Prostata-Vergrößerung.
Er leidet an Sufisienz seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 10 Jahren an Arteriella-Hypertonie.
Er leidet regelmäßig an Spironolakton, Furasemit und Candesartan.
Die Dosis ist nicht erinnerlich.
Er wurde in kurzer Zeit wahrscheinlich an Neuren-Ensuffisiens diagnostiziert.
Vor 40 Jahren wurde eine Cholesistektomie durchgeführt.
Er hat Allergien gegen Katzehaar und Hausstaub.
Er ist nicht raucher.
Er trinkt ein Glas Wein zweimal im Monat.
Er wurde verheiratet.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat 3 gesunde Kinder.
Er leidet seit 10 Jahren an Arteriella-Hypertonie.
Er leidet in der Familie Anamnese.
Er leidet bei Arteriella-Hypertonie und dem Manns.
Er leidet bei Vater, Diabetes mellitus und Arteriella-Hypertonie.
Er leidet bei der Mutter.
Der Vater und die Mutter sind im Auto-Unfall verstorben.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reise an Amnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstheorose lautet auf dem Manns.
Dafür schiebt er Amnesie, Konzentrationsstörungen, Hörstörungen.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik betrachtet Gehirntumor, Subarachnoidal, Blutung und Depression.
Zu weiteren Diagnostiken würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Zuerst würde ich die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Dabei achte ich auf Motorik, Sensorik, Reflexe.
Zu weiteren Diagnostiken würde ich eine Labouruntersuchung durchführen.
Ich würde die Entzündungswerte und die Gerinnungswerte bestimmen.
Um meine Verdachtstheorose zu bestätigen, würde ich die Schädel-MRT durchschüren.
Um meine Verdachtstheorose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde eine neurologische Konzilveranlassung durchführen, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Ich würde eine psychiatrische Konzilveranlassung durchführen.
Ich werde jetzt meinen Plan durchführen.
Frau Obererst.
Wie ist der Allgemeinszustand des Patienten orientiert?
Er weiß, wo wir jetzt sind.
Er kann sprechen. Er erinnert sich an seinen Namen.
Er leidet an nur kurze Erinnerungslücke.
Seitorientiert, nicht gut.
Ich habe es nicht gefragt.
Würden Sie eine stationäre Aufnahme empfehlen?
Ja, ich würde eine stationäre Aufnahme empfehlen.
Was warten Sie auf eine körperliche Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich Motorik, Sensibilität und Reflexe überprüfen.
Ich erwarte eigentlich keine Befunde.
Gibt es Patienten mit Suizid-Gedanken?
Er möchte nicht mehr leben, deswegen bleibt er im Untersuchungszimmer.
Was empfehlen Sie der Patienten?
Ich würde eine psychiatrische Konzilveranlassung veranlassen.
Vielleicht sollten wir eine Antidepressiva, wie Paroxetin oder Cetralin verabreichen.
Um die Therapie zu optimieren, würde ich eine psychiatrische Konzilveranlassung veranlassen.
Ich empfehle eine Psychotherapie.
Okay, der Patient kann Demos.
Deshalb brachte er eine Untersuchung.
Er möchte seine Frau in seinem Haus fragen.
Empfehlen Sie eine Unterstützung?
Oder denken Sie, er braucht eine Unterstützung?
Er lebt mit seiner Frau, ich glaube, seine Frau unterstützt ihn.
Aber seine Frau kann eine alte Frau auch.
Ich werde nachfragen.
Welche Unterstützung braucht der Demos-Patient?
Was empfehlen Sie für diesen Patienten?
Der Demos-Patient kann nicht gewohnt leben.
Der Demos-Patient braucht Hilfe beim Kochen und beim Kaufen.
Ich empfehle ihm ein Pflegeheim.
Aber seine Frau ist gesund. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie unterstützen kann.
Das ist ein Pflegeheim.
Einige Pflegeheime können besucht werden.
Sie können sich organisieren.
Der Patient hat eine depressive Stimmung.
Hat er etwas versucht?
Ich habe es nicht direkt gefragt.
Sie haben nur einen Suizidaldenken gefragt.
Wie können wir diese Fragen stellen?
Sie haben eine Vorbereitung für diese Gedanken.
Welche Therapieoptionen kommen in Frage?
Ich werde einen neurologischen und psychiatrischen Konzil veranlassen.
Ich empfehle Psychotherapie und antidepressive Medikamente.
Was warten Sie für Demos in der MRT?
Ich erwarte eine verminderte Gehirngebäude.
Denken Sie an weitere Untersuchungen?
Ich bin ein Psychotherapie- und Psychiatrie-Konzil-Patient.
Ich bin ein Psychiatrie- und Psychiatrie-Konzil-Patient.
Er hat keine Fieber.
Deswegen habe ich keine Meningitis-Gedanken.
Es könnte eine Gehirntumor- oder Gehirnblutung sein.
Ich kann die Änderung der Meningitis-Gedanken beurteilen.
Aber am Anfang kann ich die Zerstörung der Zerstörung veranlassen.
Wenn die Befunde unklar ist, kann ich eine EEG veranlassen.
Wie sind die Risikofaktoren?
Er ist alt.
In der Familienanamnesik gibt es Demos.
Er leidet an Herzinsuffizienz, arterieller Hypertonie und Niereninsuffizienz.
Das ist ein Risikofaktorenziel.
Welche Demos-Septomen sind die wichtigsten?
In diesem Fall ist es eine Erinnerungslücke.
Die Konzentrationsstörung ist ein Sprit für Demos.
Danke.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde ihn gerne vorstellen.
Ich habe die Anamnesik spontan erzählt.
Ich habe keine Notizen gemacht.
Ich werde die Anamnesik zeigen.
Es handelt sich um Hans Brenfler.
Er ist 82 Jahre alt.
Er ist 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Er hat heute Geburtstag.
Der Patient steht seit fünf bis sechs Monaten im Bezirk.
Er ist nicht mehr in der Situation.
Er kann sich nicht mehr in die Alten Dinge erinnern.
Er hat eine Konzentrationsstörung.
Er hat auch Probleme mit der Altersaktivität.
Der Patient hat einen Gewicht abgenommen.
Er war sechs Monate lang.
Er war ein altem Arzt.
Er ist altem und normal.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Er ist alt.
Er hat seit 20 Jahren eine chronische Myokartkrankheit.
Er hat auch Nierenerkrankungen.
Er hat viele Medikamente.
Er nimmt Spironolaktin, Prasemit, Kandazartan und eine Schlafmitte.
Aber die Nieren sind wirkschaftlich.
Er reagiert allergisch auf Katze, Haare und Halsstoff.
Das ist mit Nasenverstopfung, Juckreis und tränenden Augen.
Er raucht nicht.
Er trinkt gelegentlich ein, zwei oder dreimal pro Monat.
Er wird Drogenkonsum für die Würde verneint.
Er teilt mit, dass der Vater und die Mutter wegen eines Autounfalls gestorben sind.
Der Vater hat eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Die Mutter hat Diabetes, Melitis und Demenz.
Er ist verheiratet und hat drei Kinder.
Alle Kinder sind gesund.
Er ist nicht rettend, aber er hat früher als Lehrer gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Demenz aus.
Der Patient leidet unter kurzzeitigem Demenz.
Er hat Konzentrationsstörungen, Sprachstörungen, Sestörungen,
Parasthese und eine depressive Stimmung und Asthenie.
Diese Symptome sprechen für Demenz.
Die Diagnose ist hipoteriös.
Die Depression und Gehirntumor sind in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
werde ich den Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen.
Dann kann ich den Patienten die Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich werde die Diagnose unterzuchen.
Dabei werde ich darauf achten, ob es andere Veränderungen gibt.
Dann werde ich den Patienten eine CTD-Schadens durchführen.
Neben der körperlichen Untersuchung werden Labarunterzüge ein Symbol geben.
Dann werden die Patienten eine Diagnose überführen.
Dann werde ich die Blutbilds, C-Arpi, BSG, TCH, T3, T4 bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich eine Virbel-Saule- oder Meningitis-Probleme ausdrücken.
Dann werde ich den Patienten Lumbar-Funktionen planen.
Bei der Diagnose der Diagnose werden die Patienten die Lumbar-Funktionen planen.
Bei unklarem Befund werde ich den Patienten die Schadens-MRT durchführen,
um andere Pathologien auszuschließen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen,
weil der Patient viele Probleme hat und eine Suizidgedanke hat.
Es wäre sinnvoll, den Patienten stationär aufzunehmen.
Ich werde den Patienten eine neurologische Konzilanordnung
und meine Therapie des Patienten optimieren.
Als Therapie empfehle ich den Patienten eine Denephesie-Rivostigmine.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind,
werde ich in den geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie als Ziphanose-Diagnose Gehirntümer haben.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei einer Gehirntümer?
Bei Gehirntümmern ist es mir unseh,
weil der Patient keine Kopfschmerzen hat.
Ich denke, Kopfschmerzen sind sehr wichtige Symptome für Gehirntümmer.
Der Patient hat keine Paralysie, Lähmung.
Das spricht für Hirntümmer.
Ich werde den Patienten CT und MRT-DESCADES durchführen.
Können Sie MRT-DESCADES aufklären?
Das ist eine Fortbildungsunterzucht.
Mit der wir die organische Gehirn und innere Organe beurteilen können.
Diese Unterzucht hilft uns, die Erkrankungen wie Tumore,
Entzündungen, Flüssigkeit, Ansamlung und andere Erkrankungen frisch zu erkennen.
Vor der Unterzucht sollte der Patient alle Metallgestände und Schmuck abgeben.
Damit die Bildqualität nicht gut wird.
Nach der Unterzucht sollte der Patient alle Metallgestände und Schmuck abgeben.
Damit die Organe besser sichtbar werden.
Die Unterzucht dauert etwa 20-30 Minuten.
Nach der Unterzucht sollte der Patient viel trinken.
Um die Kontrastmutter schnell auf den Körper zu ausscheiden.
Es gibt keine Schütterlungbelastung.
Nach der Unterzucht sollte der Patient seine Alltagwegewohnheit fortsetzen.
In manchen Fällen kann der Patient die Erkrankungen nicht mehr beurteilen.
In manchen Fällen kann die Erkrankungen nicht mehr beurteilen.
Welche Kontraindikationen kennen Sie bei der MRT?
Wenn der Patient schweres Nierenprobleme hat, oder gegen Kontrastmutterallergie.
Oder der Patient ist schwanger.
Dann müssen wir wieder prüfen, ob diese Unterzucht möglich ist.
Oder ob es andere Unterzucht ersetzen kann.
Herzschriftmacher und Metallgestände.
Wer der Patient eine Platzangst hat, kann den Patient eine Berührungsmittel geben.
Okay, Nagut.
Guten Tag Herr Herzschriftmacher.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne ihn Ihnen vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja bitte schön.
Ich berichte über den 82-jährigen Patienten Hans Brenzler.
Der 1,73 Meter groß ist und 70 Kilogramm wiegt.
Herr Brenzler hat sich heute bei uns wegen der 3-6 Monate bestehenden Amnesie und Nervosität vorgestellt.
Begleitend sind Hörstörungen und Parastese im rechten Bein.
Er hat 5 Kilogramm Abgenommensmöglichkeiten.
Er hat 20 Jahre lang Herzinsuffizienz und Arteriehypertonie.
Er erhöhte Nierenwerte und hochwahrscheinlich Niereninsuffizienz.
Und er hat seit 10 Jahren Prostathyperplasie.
Dagegen nimmt er Spironolakton, Prostemit, Candesartan und pflanzliche Arzneimittel.
Die Dosierung und Einnahmehofigkeit sind nicht bekannt.
Und die Dosierung und Einnahmehofigkeit sollten geklärt werden.
Bei dem Patienten wurde vor 40 Jahren eine Cholestectomie durchgeführt.
Er hat Katzenfall- und Hausstauallergie, die durch Pruritis, Rhinokonjunktivitis und Oisen.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Impfunganamnese ist nicht erinnerlich.
Die Impfunganamnese sollte geklärt werden.
Er ist nicht Rauchhörer.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Alkoholkonsum ist auch unauffällig.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde vernannt.
Die Eltern von Patienten sind wegen einem Autounfall verstorben.
Bei dem Vater waren Arteriellhypertronik und Demenz bekannt.
Bei der Mutter waren Diabetes, Meletus und Arteriellhypertronik bekannt.
Er hat zwei Brüder, aber hat keinen Kontakt.
Er ist verheiratet und wohnt mit seiner Frau.
Er hat drei gesunde Kinder.
Er ist Rentner.
Er hat als Lehrer gearbeitet.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Demenz hin.
Die Differenzdiagnose kommt mit Alzeimer, Gehirntumor und intrakranierter Blutung in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
werden die Patienten zunächst körperlich und sensorisch und motorisch untersucht.
Neurologische Untersuchungen werden sinnvoll.
Ich werde natürlich Blut abnehmen.
Der Patient hat einen nicht guten Allgemeinsatz.
Deswegen werde ich Elektrolyten und Nieren und Leberwerte bestimmen lassen.
Ich werde auch ein CT des Shaders durchführen, um einige Gehirntumor oder Gehirnblutung auszuschließen.
Gehirnblutung werde ich durchführen.
Ich möchte auch Gehirnveränderungen bestimmen lassen.
Gehirnatrophy würde ich bestimmen lassen.
Eine neurologische und psychiatrische Konzil sind auch sinnvoll.
Ich werde den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, da der Patient Suizidgedachtnis hat.
Ich werde den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen und den Patienten genau zu diagnostizieren.
Welche Symptome sprechen für ein Dement bei diesem Patienten?
Der Patient leidet unter Vergisslichkeit, Gedachnis, Störungen.
Er ist nervös und hat auch Inapetenz, Schlafstörungen, Insomnie.
Diese Symptome sprechen für ein Dement oder Alzheimer.
Der Patient leidet unter Konzentrationsstörungen und Depressivverstimmung.
Kommt eine Hypothriose als Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, Herr Oberers, wir müssen auf jeden Fall Hypothriose ausschließen.
Wir müssen auch T3, T4 und TSH bestimmen lassen.
Welche Symptome sprechen für Hypothriose?
Besonders Insomnie oder ...
Der Patient leidet unter Vergisslichkeit, Gedachnis oder Insomnie.
Aber auf jeden Fall müssen wir Hypothriose ausschließen.
Welche anderen Symptome kennen Sie für eine Hypothriose?
Ja, unter einer Hypothriose kann trockene Haut, Gewichtabnahme, Konzentrationsstörungen, Kaltintoleranz und Haarausfall auftreten.
Also Konzentrationsstörungen?
Ja, Konzentrationsstörungen.
Gewichtabnahme kann auftreten.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine CT-DES-CHADERS durchführen. Können Sie bitte CT-DES-CHADERS erklären?
Ja. CT-DES-CHADERS gehört zum Bildgerändeverfahren mit Hilfestrahlen,
die Knochen oder inneren Organen beurteilen mit Hilfe CT-DES-CHADERS.
Mit Hilfe CT-DES-CHADERS können wir Gehirn und Schädelknochen beurteilen
und mögliche Blutungen oder Tumoren oder Knochenbruch beurteilen.
Der Patient liegt auf der Liegtisch und wird in Röhre eingeführt.
Dieser Verfahren dauert zwischen 5 und 10 Minuten.
Bevor dieser Verfahren, muss man nicht eine bestimmte Vorbereitung machen.
Und nach dem Verfahren kann man weitermachen.
Gehirnblutung ist ein Kontrastmittel, das wir benutzen, um die Gefäße oder Tumoren genauer zu beurteilen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Gehirnblutung als Diagnose kommt. Was erwarten Sie?
Gehirnblutung muss ein Unfall sein.
Manchmal wird spontan Gehirnblutung wegen Arterialhypertonie aufgetreten.
Aber Gehirnblutung hat besonders akute Symptome.
Der Patient hat seit 6 Monaten Bechwerden.
Viele Patienten mit Gehirnblutung haben motorische oder sensorische Symptome.
Die Zerstörung kann auch aufstehen.
Manche Patienten nehmen Antikoagulanz.
Antikoagulanz kann auch eine Gehirnblutung verursachen.
Würden Sie bei diesen Patienten eine EEG durchführen?
EEG?
Normalerweise würde ich nicht durchführen.
Der Patient hat keine epileptische Bechwerden.
Aber EEG wird durchgeführt.
Vielen Dank.